So last time we had started discussing the historical merits of the Biblical
Stories of the Patriarchs and the matriarchs.
And these are contained in genesis 12 through 50 and scholarly opinion on this
matter is seriously divided.
Something you need to know.
Some scholars were point to internal biblical evidence for the authenticity and
the antiquity of the patriarchal stories.
So for example,
narco knock him Sarna argues that a representing Abraham and Isaac and Jacob as
foreigners and strangers in Canaan is hardly a convenient tradition for a people
who are seeking to establish their claim to uh,
to its homeland.
And if this myth of origins where the fabrication of a later writer then surely
they would have written the story in such a way as to give their ancestors,
uh,
a less tenuous hold or claim connection to the land.
He also notes that some of the material in the patriarchal stories would be
offensive to later religious sensibilities.
Jacob is married to two sisters simultaneously.
That is something that is explicitly forbidden in the book of Deuteronomy.
So why wouldn't a later right or have cleaned up this,
uh,
ancestral record,
if this were in fact something composed at a later period.
Also,
he notes that the representation of interethnic relationships in the patriarchal
stories,
um,
do not accord with the reality of a later period.
So for example,
the Arameans are considered close kin to the Israelites.
So wandering Arameans was my father.
It says,
uh,
and uh,
spouses are always chosen.
Daughters for sons are always chosen by going back to the Armenian people and
choosing someone,
some close kin,
but in the period of the monarchy,
right?
So that's going to be after 1000 in the period of the monarchy.
Um,
there were very poor relations with the Armenians.
They were bitter enemies.
So why,
according to scholars like Sarna would a biblical author from that period
portray the Arameans as close kin unless they had some older tradition
established tradition that reflected that fact.
So Sarna and other scholars hold that the patriarchal traditions are not
entirely fabricated.
Retro ejections from a later period.
They contain authentic memories of an earlier historic situation.
The patriarchs,
it's maintained.
We're semi nomads.
They lived in tents from time to time.
They wander to Egypt or Mesopotamia often in search of pasture for their animals
and various details of their language,
their customs,
their laws,
their religion.
It's argued seem to fit well into the period of the late bronze age of giving
you three.
I'm giving you the,
the periods at the top of the chart.
Early Bronze Age,
Middle Bronze Age from about 2100 to 1550 we date the late bronze age from about
1550 until 1200 the introduction of iron and the beginning of the Iron Age in
1200 prior to that,
the Bronze Age,
which is divided into these three periods,
so that's on the one hand scholars who see these stories as reflecting
historical memories and having a certain authenticity to them.
Then on the other hand,
at the other extreme,
you have scholars who see the patriarchal stories is entirely fabricated,
retro ejections of a much later age and they varied significantly as to when
they think these stories were written anywhere from the period of a monarchy all
the way down to the fourth century.
Some of them works published in the 1970s by authors like Thomas Thompson,
John Mann,
cedars take the position that these stories are filled with anachronisms.
There chronologies are confused.
These anachronisms and confused chronologies in the patriarchal stories are the
rule rather than the exception in their view.
And they are evidence of a very late date of composition.
So you have these two extremes based on the internal evidence of the Bible
itself,
but you also have the same two extreme positions reflected in the discipline of
archeology.
In the early days,
uh,
archeology of the region tended toward credulity and it was explicitly referred
to as biblical archeology and interesting name because it suggests that the
archeologists were out there searching for evidence that would verify the
details of the biblical text.
We're doing biblical archaeology,
archaeology,
and support of,
of the biblical text.
I mentioned last time,
William f all bright and American archeologist.
He believed strongly that archeological findings were important external
evidence for the basic historicity and authenticity of,
for example,
the patriarchal stories.
And certainly some archeological findings were quite remarkable.
Um,
scholars of the Albright School pointed to texts and clay tablets that were
discovered in second millennium sites.
So you see it on the bottom,
second millennium,
BC obviously going down to 1001st millennium,
1000 to zero.
And the second millennium really wasn't longer than the first millennium is just
that I ran out of board.
But specifically cites like newsy and Mari,
I've placed them in their approximate places on the timeline.
New Zealand Maori were sites that are near the area that's identified in the
Bible as being the ancestral home of the Patriarchs and Mesopotamia or on the
highway from there to Canaan.
And these texts and clay tablets were believed to aluminate many biblical
customs in institutions.
So in the newsy techs,
which are from about the middle of the second millennium,
we learned that the custom of adoption for purposes of inheritance,
particularly the adoption of a slave in the absence of offspring and biblical
scholars got very excited about this.
They point to the biblical passage in which Abraham expresses to God his fear
that his servant Eliezer,
we'll have to be the one to inherit God's promised because Abraham has no a son.
Also,
according to the new z texts,
if a wife is barren,
she is to provide a maid servant as a substitute to bear her husband's children.
And this is something that happens with three out of the four matriarchs who are
afflicted with infertility,
Sarah,
Rachel and Leah.
There are other parallels in family and marriage law that correlate with certain
biblical details.
And the 18th century,
the texts from Mari,
they contain names that correspond to Israelite names.
Benjamin,
Laban,
Ishmael.
So Biblical scholars,
uh,
Boyd up by these correlations between the archeological finds,
the texts found by archeologists and Biblical stories asserted that the
Patriarchs were real persons and their customs and their legal practices and
their social institutions could be verified against the backdrop of second
millennium of the second Millennium as revealed by archeological findings.
However,
it's been argued that some of these ancient sources have been misread or
misinterpreted in an effort to find parallels with biblical institutions.
A lot of gap filling is going on to make these texts look as though they
correspond to biblical institutions and skeptics like Thomas Thompson and John
Van Cedar's.
Point out that many of the biblical customs which are paralleled in ancient near
eastern sources were still alive and well down in the first millennium.
So references to these customs and the patriarchal stories really doesn't tell
us anything about dating they could derive from anywhere in the second or first
millennium.
And for other reasons,
they think it is much more reasonable to date the composition of these stories
to the first millennium in some cases quite late first millennium.
Furthermore,
over time,
many discrepancies between the archaeological record and the biblical text
became apparent and increasingly practitioners of what was now being termed
Palestinian archeology or ancient near eastern archeology or archaeology of the
Lavant rather than biblical archeology.
Some of these archeologists grew disinterested in pointing out the correlations
between the archeological data and the biblical stories are trying to explain
away any discrepancies in order to keep the biblical texts intact.
And they began to focus on the best possible reconstruction of the history of
the region on the basis of the archaeological evidence,
regardless of whether or not those results would confirm the biblical texts,
the biblical account,
and in fact this reconstruction often does contradict biblical claims.
We're going to see this quite clearly,
um,
in a few weeks when we consider the book of Joshua and it story of Israel's
lightening invasion of the land of Canaan,
the archeological record just doesn't support such a such a story still,
uh,
many people have clung to the idea of the Bible as a historically accurate
document.
Many times out of ideological necessity.
Many fear that if the historical information in the Bible isn't true,
then the Bible is unreliable as a source of religious instruction or
inspiration.
And that's something they don't want to give up.
And this is all really a very unfortunate and heavy burden to place on this
fascinating little library of writings from late antiquity.
People who equate truth with historical fact will certainly end up viewing the
Bible dismissively as a naive and unsophisticated web of lies since it is
replete with elements that cannot be literally true.
But to view it this way is to make a genre mistake.
Shakespeare's hamlet while set in Denmark and actual place is not historical
fact,
but that doesn't make it a naive and unsophisticated web of lies because we
accept when we read or watch hamlet that it is not a work of historiography or
work of writing about history.
It is a work of literature and in deference to that genre and it's conventions
we know and accept that the truth it conveys are not those of historical fact,
but our social,
political,
ethical,
existential truths.
And the Bible deserves at least the same courteous attention to its genre.
The Bible doesn't pretend to be and it shouldn't be read as what we would call
objective history.
And then to see the scare quotes,
you should be looking up there.
So you see the scare quotes,
objective history,
in other words,
perhaps a bear narration of events.
Um,
to be sure,
we do find that some events that are mentioned in the biblical texts correlate
to events that we know of from sources outside the Bible.
So for example,
Faro,
she shacks,
invasion of Palestine,
and nine 24.
This is mentioned in the biblical text.
It's mentioned in the Egyptian sources.
There's a nice correlation,
the destruction of the northern Kingdom of Israel and seven 22,
um,
the capture of Jerusalem and five 97 the destruction of the temple in Jerusalem
and five 86.
These are all recorded in the biblical text and they are in a Syrian and
Babylonian records as well,
as well as other events from the period of the monarchy.
So as a result,
because of these correlations,
many scholars are willing to accept the general biblical chronology of the
period from the monarchy on deciding about a thousand on.
They accept that general chronology,
the sequence of kings and battles and so on.
But ultimately it is a mistake,
I think,
to read the Bible as a historical record.
The Bible is literature.
It's composition is influenced and determined by literary conventions and goals.
Now,
of course we all know that there is no such thing as purely objective,
purely objective history anyway.
We have no direct access to past events.
We only ever have mediated access in material archaeological remains that yield
information to us only after a process of interpretation or in texts that are
themselves already an interpretation of events and must still be interpreted by
us.
The biblical narrative is an interpretation of events that were held by
century's long tradition to be meaningful in the life of the people and to the
biblical narrators.
These events known perhaps from ancient oral traditions pointed to a divine
purpose and the narrative is told to illustrate that basic proposition.
The biblical narrators are not trying to write history as a modern historian
might try to do write history.
They are concerned to show us what they believe to be the finger of God in the
events and experiences of the Israelite people.
A one scholar Mark Brittler whose name I've also put up here.
Um,
mark rettler notes that in the Bible,
the past is refracted through a theological lens,
if not a partisan political,
ideological lens.
But then all ancient historical narrative is written that way.
And one could argue all contemporary historical narrative is written that way.
With due caution,
we can still learn things from texts,
ancient and modern.
We can still learn things about Israel's history from the biblical sources.
Just as classical historians have learned a great deal about classical history,
Greece and Rome,
despite or through the tendentious partisan and ideologically motivated writings
of classical writers.
So our discussion of the patriarchal stories is going to bear all of these
considerations in mind.
We're not going to be asking whether these stories are historically accurate.
I'm going to assume they are not.
And once we rid ourselves of the burden of historicity,
we're free to appreciate the stories for what they are.
Powerful,
powerful narratives that must be read against the literary conventions of their
time and whose truths are social,
political,
moral,
and existential.
So what are these truths will begin to answer this question,
begin to answer this question.
You'll spend the rest of your life finishing the process of answering this
question,
but we'll begin by identifying some by no means all of the major themes of
genesis 12 through 50 and we're going to begin with a story of [inaudible] rock
and his family.
This is a story that's marked by the themes of divine command and divine
promise.
Now,
the biblical writer represents the emigration of Terex son,
a brother whose name will be changed to Abraham.
So sometimes I'll say one and sometimes the other,
but they represent his immigration as divinely commanded.
It's the first step in a journey that will lead ultimately to the formation of a
nation in covenant with God.
And first we meet our cast of characters.
This is in genesis 11 versus 27 on through chapter 12 verse three.
Now these are the generations of Tara [inaudible],
Abraham Nahor and Haran and Heran.
We got lot and her Ron died in the presence of his father,
Tay Rock in the land of his birth in or of the deans and Abraham and the whore
took them wives,
the name of Abram's wife.
With Sarah,
we will become Sara and the name of for his wife Milkah and Sarah was barren.
She had no child.
Tareq took Abraham,
his son and lot the son of Heran,
his grandson and Sarah,
his daughter in law,
his son,
Abram's wife getting confused yet.
And they went forth together from the or from or of the Kelty ins to go into the
land of Canaan.
But when they came to her,
Ron,
they settled there in the days of Terah were 205 years than t rock died in
Haran.
And now the Lord said to Abraham,
go from your country and your kindred and your father's house to the land that I
will show you.
I will make of you a great nation and I will bless you and make your name great
so that you will be a blessing.
I will bless those who bless you and him who curses you.
I will curse.
And by all by you all the families of the earth shall bless themselves.
So Abraham is commanded to go forth from his home and family to a location to be
named later.
Alright,
a location that remains for now unspecified,
and this is a fact that it's caused commentators for centuries to praise him for
his faith,
and that is a virtue.
Faith is a virtue that is connected or associated with Abraham,
Abraham in other biblical context and also in later religious tradition.
He is seen as the paradigm,
the paradigmatic exemplar of a man of faith.
The command is coupled with a promise.
I will make a view.
God says a great nation and I will bless you,
but we have just learned in chapter 11 that Sarah is barren.
It was a seemingly irrelevant detail.
Who's import is suddenly clear.
How clever of the narrator to plant the information.
We need to realize that Abraham has to take God's word on faith and how
perfectly the narrator's sets up the dramatic tension and the great confusion
that is going to run through the next several chapters because Abraham doesn't
seem to understand that the progeny will come from Sarah and you have to read
these stories as if you're reading them for the first time.
You have the great disadvantage of knowing the ending.
It's a terrible disadvantage.
You have to discipline yourself to read these stories as if you don't know
what's coming next.
And put yourself in the position of the character evens just been told he's
going to be the father of great nations and he has a barren wife.
Right?
Why should he think?
He doesn't seem to understand that the project he's going to come from Sarah,
and why should he think that it would?
God wasn't specific.
He simply says,
I shall make a view a great nation.
He says nothing of Sarah.
And after all,
she's barren.
So Abrah may be forgiven for thinking that perhaps some other mate awaits him.
And so he surrenders her easily to other men,
to Pharaoh of Egypt.
Immediately following this scene in the next chapter in chapter,
um,
this scene in chapter 11,
immediately after that in Egypt,
he surrenders her,
he willingly accept Sarah's offer of a handmaid,
Hagar to bear a child,
Ishmael in Sarah's place.
How cleverly the narrator leads us with Avram to pin our hopes on your smile as
the child of the promise.
And how cleverly is the carpet pulled out from under our feet?
In genesis 17 when God finally perhaps impatiently talk specifics.
No,
I meant that you would father a great nation through Sarah and Abraham as he is
now called is incredulous.
She's past the age of bearing Lord and he laughs and God is silent and in that
silence I always imagined that this light goes on this click,
this awful sickening light,
and Abraham says,
oh,
that Ishmael might live in your site or something like that.
I think I probably misquoted,
oh,
that Ishmael might live by your favor.
Sorry,
that's the actual words.
But God is determined.
Sarah will bear Isaac and with him,
God will make an everlasting covenant.
All of this drama through the first five chapters made possible by a seemingly
irrelevant line and 1130 sort of throw away datum and a family list that one
might gloss over and Sarah was barren.
She had no child.
And that's the power and beauty of biblical narrative and you have to get
yourself into the mindset to read it that way.
A few verses later when Abraham and his wife Sarah and his nephew lot and those
traveling with them all reach Canaan,
God makes an additional promise.
He says in verse seven I will assign this land to your offspring.
So in just a few short verses,
right,
we've just gone from 12 and just gone seven versus now into chapter 12 in just a
few short verses,
the writer has established the threefold promise that underpins the biblical
drama that's about to unfold the promise of progeny of blessing and of land,
and that establishes a narrative tension for the stories of the patriarch,
but also for the story of the nation of Israel in subsequent books,
because in the patriarchal stories,
there is this suspenseful vacillation between episodes that threatened to
extinguish God's promise and episodes that reaffirm them.
Israelite matriarchs seem to be a singularly in fertile group.
The lines of inheritance defy our expectations.
It doesn't seem to go to the person.
We think that it's going to go to the process by which the promise is fulfilled,
his halting and torturous at times.
We're going to look at one example of an episode in which the promise is
affirmed and uh,
or confirmed,
reaffirmed and an example of an episode in which the promises supremely
threatened.
In Genesis 15,
God's promise to Abraham is formalized in a ritual ceremony.
God and Abraham are said to cut a covenant.
That's the verb that's used in making a covenant.
And Covenant is Essential Biblical concept.
The Hebrew word for covenant,
which I've written over here is breached means vow,
promise,
perhaps contract agreement or packed parallels to the biblical covenant have
been pointed out by many ancient near eastern historians and scholars.
Um,
we have in our ancient near eastern texts,
and we'll come back to these in more detail when we get into exodus,
but we have in our ancient near eastern texts,
two types,
two main types of Covenant Suzerainty Covenant and a parity covenant.
As you can imagine from the name as suzerainty covenant is the Covenant in which
was Superior Party as Susan dictates the terms of a political treaty usually,
um,
and in a farrier party obeys them.
And the arrangement primarily serves the interests of the Susan.
Right.
And not not the vassal or the subject.
In a parity covenant,
you have really two equal parties who both agree to observe the provisions of
some kind of treaty.
Now there are four major covenants in the Hebrew Bible.
They're initiated by yeah,
way as expressions of divine favor and graciousness.
And two of these appear in Genesis.
We've already seen one,
the Noaa Hide Covenant and the Abrahamic Covenant,
which we're looking at now.
Now the Noaa Hide Covenant in Genesis nine verses one through 17 is universal in
scope that encompasses all life on earth.
It stresses the sanctity of life.
And in this covenant,
God promises never to destroy all life.
Again.
By contrast,
the Abrahamic Covenant is a covenant with a single individual.
So we've gone from a covenant with all of humanity to a covenant with a single
individual,
and it looks very much like in ancient near eastern suzerainty covenant.
God appears as a Susan.
He's making a land grant to a favorite subject,
which is very often how these work.
And,
uh,
there's an ancient ritual that ratifies the oath.
Um,
in general,
a suzerainty in,
in this kind of covenant.
The parties to the oath would pass between the split carcass of a sacrificial
animal as if to say that they agree they will suffer the same fate as this
animal if they violate the covenant.
So in Genesis 15 Abraham cuts sacrificial animals and to and God,
but only God passes between the two halves.
The striking thing about the Abrahamic covenant is it's unilateral character
only.
God seems to be obligated by the covenant obligated to fulfill the promise that
he's made.
Abraham doesn't appear to have any obligation in return,
and so in this case,
it is the subject,
Abraham and not the Susan God who is benefited by this covenant.
That's a complete reversal of our expectation.
Note also that the biblical writer goes out of his way to provide a moral
justification for this grant of land to Israel.
In the biblical writers view,
God is the owner of the land,
and so he is empowered to set conditions or residency requirements for those who
would reside in it like a landlord.
The current inhabitants of the land are polluting it,
filling it with bloodshed and idolatry,
and when the land becomes so polluted,
completely polluted,
it will spew out its inhabitants.
That process,
God says,
isn't complete,
so Israel is going to have to wait,
right?
The least isn't up yet,
and the Israelites will have to wait.
He says in Genesis 15 verse 16 the Iniquity of the Amorites will not be
fulfilled until then.
So here and in other places in the Bible,
it's clear that God's Israel,
God's covenant with Israel is not due to any special merit of the Israelites or
favoritism.
This is actually said explicitly in Deuteronomy.
Rather,
God is seeking replacement tenants who are going to follow the moral rules of
residents that he has established for his land.
Genesis 17 seems to be a second version of the same covenant.
This time of scholars attributed to p,
the priestly writer,
the piece source,
and there are some notable differences emphasizing themes that were important to
the priestly writer.
So God adds to the promises in genesis 17 that align of kings will come forth
from Abraham and then that Abraham and his male descendants be circumcised as a
perpetual sign of the covenant.
So here there is some obligation for Abraham.
Thus shall my covenant be marked in your flesh as an everlasting packed.
Failure to circumcise is tantamount to breaking the covenant according to the
text.
Now,
circumcision is known in many of the cultures of the ancient near east.
It's generally a rite of passage that was performed at the time of puberty,
um,
rather than a ritual that was performed at birth eight days after birth.
So that's unusual and the Israelite context to have it occur with infants.
Um,
but as is the case with so many biblical rituals or institutions or laws,
whatever their original meaning or significance in the ancient world,
whether this was originally a puberty rite or fertility,
right of some kind,
um,
the ritual has been suffused with a new meaning in our texts.
And so circumcision is here infused with a new meaning.
It becomes a sign of God's eternal covenant with Abraham and his seed.
So these texts are typical of affirmations of God's promise,
but despite them,
the patriarchal episodes or stories are peppered with episodes in which the
realization of the promise and blessing is threatened.
In Chapter 12,
Avram surrenders his wife,
Sarah,
to Pharaoh in order to advance his position among the Egyptians plausibly not
knowing that it is Sarah who was supposed to bear the child of God's promises.
I said,
that's left unclear until chapter 17,
when God says,
no,
you misunderstood.
I met Sarah.
God intervenes,
however,
and returns Sarah to Abraham.
Sarah is barren.
State really casts a shadow over the promise from the very beginning of the
story of Abraham and Sarah.
Desperate,
Sarah takes advantage of the custom that is a tested in the ancient world of
giving her Egyptian handmaid,
Hagar,
to Abraham to bear a child in her stead.
But Hagar Apparently Lourdes this over her mistress and,
and embittered Sarah forces her from the house.
Hagar and her child is my smile.
Cry Out to God in the wilderness.
And God assures Hagar that Ishmael,
who is regarded by Muslims is the ancestor of the Arabs.
And uh,
the inheritor of the blessing and the promise addition,
my El shall become a great nation too.
But really the greatest threat to the promise comes from God himself.
And that is in genesis 22,
when God tests Abraham with the most horrible of demands,
the child of the promise,
Isaac,
who's born miraculously to Sarah when she was no longer of child bearing age,
is to be sacrificed to God by Abraham's own hand.
And the story of the binding of Isaac is one of the most powerful,
most riveting stories,
not only in the Bible,
but some have claimed in all of world literature.
The story is a marvelous examplar exemplar of the biblical narrator's literary
skill and artistry.
This week's assigned reading includes selections from Robert Alters Book.
The Art of Biblical narrative,
which I heartily recommend to read in its entirety.
Alter describes the extreme economy of Biblical narrative economy in the
description of physical settings and character,
as well as speech.
Rarely does their narrator comment on or explain a character's actions or
thoughts or motives.
There's only the barest minimum of dialogue.
And on the few occasions that the Bible will violate this principle of verbally
economy.
For example,
if two characters converse at length,
you can be sure it's significant.
You want to pay extra attention,
the biblical narratives,
concealing of details and the motives of the characters,
God and Abraham and Isaac leads to ambiguity and the possibility of very many
interpretations.
And that is a striking characteristic of biblical prose.
It's suppression of detail.
It's terse,
laconic style that makes the little,
that is given so powerful.
So fraught with background to use the phrase of Erich Auerbach,
uh,
whose article you are also to read this week.
Auerbach contrasts the literary style of homer with the biblical writers style,
specifically in connection with the story of genesis 22,
the ambiguities and the indeterminacy of the story.
Make it one of the most interpreted texts of all time.
Why is God testing Abraham?
Does God really desire such a sacrifice?
What is Abraham thinking and feeling as he walks for three days,
already walks with his son and bearing the wood and the fire for the sacrifice.
Does he fully intend to obey this command to and the covenantal promise with his
own hand,
or does he trust in God to intervene or is this a paradox of faith?
Does Abraham intend faithfully to obey all the while trusting faithfully that
God's promised will nevertheless be fulfilled?
What's Isaac thinking?
Does he understand what is happening?
How old is he?
Is this a little boy or a grown man?
Is He prepared to obey?
He sees the wood and the Firestone in his father's hand.
Clearly a sacrifice.
His plant,
he's got three days to figure that out.
He asks his father,
where is the sheep for the burnt offering?
Does he know the answer?
Even as he asks,
does a here the double entendre and his father's very simple and solemn reply,
which in the unpunctuated Hebrew might be red?
The Lord will provide the sheep for the offering.
My son,
does he struggle when he's bound?
Does he acquiesce?
The beauty of the narrative is it's sheer economy.
It offers so little that we as readers are forced to imagine the innumerable
possibilities.
We play out the drama in countless ways with an Abraham who is reluctant and an
Isaac was ignorant or an Abraham who's eager to serve his God to the point of
sacrificing his own son and an Isaac who willingly bares his neck to the knife.
Read the story one verse,
one phrase,
one word at a time.
There were so few words that you can be sure that they were chosen with care.
You'll be looking at genesis 22 closely in your section discussions and as you
read the story,
remember it's larger context.
God's promise to make Abraham the father of a great people through his son
Isaac.
It's in this context,
it's this context,
this promise that gives the story.
It's special power and Pathos,
but of course the story can be contextualized in a number of different ways.
For example,
one can read the story in its historical context of child sacrifice in the
ancient near east.
Although child sacrifice was adamantly condemned in various later layers of the
Bible,
there's plenty of evidence that it was probably practiced in different quarters
throughout the period of the monarchy.
Does genesis 22 assume or reject the practice of child sacrifice?
Some scholars argue that a core story promoting child sacrifice has been edited,
so as to serve as a polemic against child sacrifice.
Now in its final form,
do you think so can you see the seams and feel the narrative tensions that would
support such a claim?
Does the story pull in more than one direction or we can read the story in its
immediate literary context.
Abraham has just permitted the expulsion of Ishmael,
the only beloved son of Hagar.
And now God demands that he sacrificed his beloved son.
What might he be trying to teach Abraham?
Is this a trial in the sense of a test or a trial in the sense of a punishment?
The Hebrew term can tolerate both meanings or genesis 22 can be contextualized
another way.
And at this point we need to backtrack a little bit to the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah,
which is in genesis 18 and 19,
uh,
to contextualize the story a little bit.
Um,
in terms of Abraham's character development,
in the story of Sodom and Gomorrah in genesis 18 and 19,
Yahweh,
he tells Abraham of his plan to investigate reports of the wickedness of the
city.
Uh,
the Canaanite city of Saddam Saddam.
Um,
it's violence,
it's cruelty to strangers and to destroy it.
And Abraham's reaction comes as something of a surprise.
He objects to the plan and he starts to argue with God.
Will you sweep away the innocence along with the guilty shall not the judge of
all the earth deal justly.
That's in genesis 18 verses 23 to 25.
The question is,
of course,
rhetorical.
Abraham is evidently quite confident that God,
God would not act unjustly,
but not destroy the innocent along with the wicked.
Indeed,
Abraham is banking on the fact that God is merciful and will overlook evil for
the sake of righteous individuals.
And so Abraham haggles with God for the lives of the innocent shall not the
judge of all the earth deal justly.
And the Lord answered,
if I find within the city of Sodom 50 innocent ones,
I will forgive the whole place for their sake.
Abraham spoke up saying,
here,
I'd venture to speak to my Lord I who am but dust and ashes.
What if the 50 innocent should lack five would you destroy the whole city for
want of the five?
And he answered,
I will not destroy it if I find 45 there.
But he spoke to him again and said,
what a 40 should be found there?
And he answered,
I will not do it for the sake of the 40 and he said,
let not my Lord be angry if I go on,
but what if 30 should be found there?
And in this way,
Abraham manages to widdle the number down to 10 and God answers,
I will not destroy for the sake of 10 men,
but 10 innocent men are not found.
The narrator makes that very clear.
He takes pains to point out that the mob that comes to abuse the to divine
visitors includes all the people to the last man,
very clear statement.
And so Saddam and his four sister,
cities of the plain around the Dead Sea are destroyed.
But out of consideration for Abraham Abraham's nephew,
lot is saved.
Genesis 19 Verse 29 God was mindful of Abraham and we moved a lot from the midst
of the upheaval.
Now,
this text is often identified as the source for the doctrine of the merit of the
righteous,
which is the idea that someone who is not righteous is spared for the sake of or
on a crown,
on account of the accrued merit of one who is righteous.
So lot himself is no prize,
but he is spared on Abraham's account.
It's an idea that will have repercussions in later biblical thought.
In this story,
we see Abraham rising to the defense of a thoroughly wicked and reprehensible
group of people arguing quite pointedly that the innocent should never be
wantonly destroy.
Can this be the same Abraham who a few chapters later when told to slaughter his
only son,
his perfectly innocent and presumably deeply loved son not only makes no
objection,
but rises early in the morning to get started on the long journey to the
sacrificial site.
What are we to make of the juxtaposition of these two stories which represents
behavior more desirable to God
before leaving the story?
I just want to make two quick comments.
First,
I've included in your a reading packet and it's uploaded on the website.
Very interesting article by a writer who relates her efforts since childhood to
understand why lot's wife should have been turned into a pillar of salt,
um,
as,
uh,
as punishment for looking back as she fled from her burning home.
It's not a biblical scholar,
but someone who simply reacting to reading the text and reacting to the text.
Was this in fact a punishment or was it a mercy?
Second,
the story of Sodom and Gomorrah has often been cited as a biblical condemnation
of homosexuality as if the sodomites were condemned to destruction because of
homosexual behavior and affect the very terms.
Sodomy and sodomized represent this interpretation,
but the idea that the fundamental sin of Sodom was homosexual behavior is not
present in the Hebrew Bible.
It appears only in later documents it's found in the Christian New testament in
the book of Jude,
Chapter Seven,
verse two,
look at Peter Chapter Two verses six through 10 and subsequent interpretations.
The sodomites like the generation of the flood stand,
condemned by the outcry against them to get a Hebrew word that's used to refer
to outcry.
It's a term that's generally associated with the Ph.
The appeal of victims of violent oppression,
bloodshed,
injustice,
the sodomites.
God hears this outcry of victims against the sodomites,
the sodomites,
violation of the unwritten desert,
law of hospitality to strangers.
They're violent desire to abuse and getting ranked,
the strangers that they should have been sheltering,
and this is merely one instance of a pattern of violence brutality.
Well,
Isaac,
who was the child of God's promised Abraham is often described as the most
invisible of the Patriarchs are the most passive of the Patriarchs,
perhaps is passive acceptance of his father's effort to sacrifice him serves as
the key to the biblical narrators perception of his character.
By contrast,
his wife,
Rebecca,
is often described as the most determined and energetic of the matriarchs.
She runs to accent,
extend hospitality to a stranger.
She quickly draws water for him.
She quickly draws water for his camels and waters them all.
She seems to run everywhere and she does all this.
Not knowing that the man she greets is a servant of Abraham who's come to seek a
wife for his master's son Isaac.
Rebecca herself personally accepts the offer of an unknown bridegroom in a far
away land and overrides the urgings of her mother and her brother to delay her
departure.
No,
she says,
I'm ready to go.
I'll go.
Now.
There's a very moving conclusion to the [inaudible] story.
Um,
we read in Genesis 24 verse 67 that Isaac brought Rebecca into the tent of his
mother's Sarah,
and he took Rebecca as his wife.
Isaac loved her and thus found comfort after his mother's death.
But like the other matriarchs,
Rebecca is barren.
So Isaac pleads with the Lord for a child on her behalf and Rebecca becomes
pregnant with twins.
The older child is Esau.
Esau will be the father of the Edomites,
and the younger is Jacob who will be the father of the Israelites.
Now,
Jacob is the most fully developed,
the most colorful,
and the most complex of the Patriarchs.
Jacob has long been identified by commentators as the classic trickster,
a type that we know from folklore.
Mark Brittler has described the Jacobs stories as a kind of morality tale.
The main message of which is trick and you shall be tricked.
Jacob tricks his brother out of his birthright and in turn is tricked by his
brother in law,
his wife and later his own sons.
How much of Jacob's trickery is really necessary after all,
Rebecca,
who suffers tremendous pain during her pregnancy is told by God that the twins
who are fighting and struggling for priority in her womb will become two
nations.
The younger,
the older of which will serve the younger that happens in genesis 25 verse 23
two nations are in your room to separate peoples shell issue from your body.
One people shall be mightier than the other and the older shall serve the
younger and indeed the real life.
Nations of Israel and he dom were longtime enemies because Esau is the father of
the Itta Mites.
According to the biblical text and for a time Aidan was subjugated by Israel.
According to the biblical text under David King David,
some scholars like knock him Sarna,
have argued that this announcement that the older shall serve the younger,
um,
if the narrator's way of establishing for the reader that the younger child,
Jacob is the son who will inherit the divine blessing.
And that that then raises serious questions about Rebecca and Jacobs morally
dubious efforts to rest the blessing and birthright from Esau.
Are we supposed to be comforted by the fact that they are fulfilling a divine
plan?
Are we supposed to conclude that it's all right to fulfill a divine plan by any
means,
fair or foul?
Or are we to conclude as Sarna and others suggest that Jacob's possession of the
birthright was predetermined.
It was disengaged from all of his acts of trickery.
And if so,
then Jacob's efforts are indicative of a deceitful and narcissistic personality.
He takes advantage of Esau as hunger,
offering him a pot of lentil stew and exchange for the birthright.
He and Rebecca plot to deceive Isaac in his dotage into bestowing the blessing
of the first born on Jacob instead of you saw so perhaps by informing us that
Jacob had been chosen from the womb,
the narrator is able to paint a portrait of Jacob at this stage in his life as
grasping and faithless a great contrast to his grandfather Abraham.
Now Jacobs poor treatment of his brother Esau earns him.
Esau is enmity and Jacob finds it expedient to leave Canaan and remain at the
home of his mother's brother.
Laban on his way east back to Mesopotamia from Canaan where leave and resides in
Mesopotamia.
Jacob has an encounter with God at a place called lose.
Jacob lies down to sleep,
um,
resting his head on a stone and he has a dream in which he sees a ladder.
The ladders feet are on the earth.
It reaches to heaven.
And there are angels ascending and descending on the ladder.
And in the dream,
yeah,
halfway appears or God appears to Jacob and reaffirms the Abrahamic or
patriarchal covenant.
He promises land posterity.
And in addition,
Jacobs own safety,
his own personal safety.
Uh,
until he returns to the land of Israel.
And Jacob is stunned.
We read in Genesis 28 versus 16 and 17,
Jacob woke from his sleep and said,
surely the Lord is in this place.
And I did not know it.
Shake.
And he said,
how awesome is this place?
This is none other than the abode of God.
And that is the gateway to heaven.
The stone that served as his pillow.
Um,
he then sets up as a cultic pillar,
some sort of memorial stone.
He sanctifies the stone with oil and he renames the site,
Beth El Bait l,
which means the house of God.
But it's significant that despite this direct vision,
Jacob,
so unlike Abraham,
is still reluctant to rely on God and his promise,
and he makes a conditional vow.
If God remains with me,
and if he protects me on this journey that I am making and gives me bread to eat
and clothing to wear,
and if I returned safe to my father's house,
the Lord shall be my God.
And this stone which I have set up as a pillar,
shall be God's boat and have all that you give me.
I will set aside a time for you.
So where once God had tested Abraham,
it seems now that Jacob is almost testing God.
If you can do all this fine,
you can be my God.
Well,
Jacob's spins some 14 years in the household of his uncle,
his mother's brother,
Laban and Jacob Meets Layman's two daughters.
Leah is the elder daughter and Rachel is the younger and he soon loves Rachel.
He agrees to serve Laban for seven years for the hand of the younger daughter.
Rachel.
When the seven years pass,
Laban deceived Jacob and gives him the elder daughter,
Leah.
Jacob.
The trickster is furious at having been tricked himself.
And in much the same way,
an older and a younger sibling,
um,
are one disguised as the other or wearing the covering of the other justice.
He tricked his own father,
but he is willing to give seven years more service for Rachel,
Rachel,
Leah,
and they're two handmaidens will conceive one daughter and 12 sons from whom
will come.
The 12 tribes of Israel,
but it's the two sons of Rachel,
the beloved wife,
the two sons of Rachel Joseph and Benjamin,
who are the most beloved to Jacob.
Jacob determines finally to leave Laban and returned to Canaan.
And there's one final remarkable incident in Jacob's life that occurs on his
return journey.
It's an incident that most readers associated with a significant transformation
in his character,
and that is Jacob's nighttime struggle with a mysterious figure who in some way
is representative of God.
And this struggle occurs as he is about to cross the river Jabbok and reconcile
himself with his former rival and enemy.
Uh,
Esau.
Jacob has set everyone on a head.
His wives,
his children,
his household,
his possessions,
he standing alone at the river.
And we read
Genesis 32 verses 25 to 33 a man wrestled with him until the break of dawn when
he saw that he had not prevailed against him.
He wrenched Jacob's hip at its socket so that the socket of his hip was strained
as he wrestled with him.
And then he said,
let me go for dawn is breaking.
But he answered,
I will not let you go unless you bless me,
said the other.
What is your name?
He replied.
Jacob said,
he,
your name shall no longer be Jacob,
but Israel,
Israel,
for you have striven with God and men and have prevailed.
Jacob asked to pray,
tell me your name,
but he said,
you must not ask my name,
and he took leave of him there.
So Jacob named the place Peniel meaning I have seen a divine being face to face,
yet my life has been preserved.
The Sun rose upon him as he passed Peniel limping on his hip.
Many scholars,
Michael Kuvan and others see this story as an Israelite adaptation of popular
stories of river gods who threaten those who wished to cross the river or trolls
or Ogres who I'm guard rivers and have to be defeated by a hero,
making the river safe to cross.
And in its Israelite version.
However,
this story is historicized.
It serves an ideological function.
So it's associated with one particular character and a historical time.
And it serves to explain why the Israelites,
it's abstain from eating the sciatic nerve of an animal.
Even to this day.
Um,
we also learn how [inaudible] gets its name.
We learned how Israel gets his name.
Names aren't important.
Theme of this story in the biblical context,
names encapsulate the essence of their bearer.
Naming something or knowing the name of something gives one control over or
power over that thing.
And that's why the stranger will not reveal his name to Jacob.
It would give Jacob power over him.
Jacob's own name is the occasion for some punning in this story.
His name is built on this route.
Yacov it means to supplant or uproot.
He emerges from the womb.
Grasping his brothers.
He'll give here.
They worked for heal is a based on that route.
It's part of his effort to supplant Issar right at birth.
And he continues that effort.
It's a planting through his early life.
The writer makes that explicit in genesis 27 verse 36 when Esau cries out,
what's he then named the alcove that he might supplant me these two times.
Um,
yes.
And in this chapter,
Jacob wrestles,
the word for wrestle is Ja is built on this route.
Just switching to letters.
He wrestles with the mysterious divine being at the yacht buck river.
So you see all of these,
these,
this punning with the name,
Jacob's very name,
hints at and foreshadows the struggling,
the wrestling,
the trickery that are the major themes of his life.
But his striving has reached a climax here.
And so the angel named him Israel,
Israel,
which means he who has striven with God because as a stranger says,
he has striven and wrestled all his life with men,
particularly as brother.
And now with God.
El Means God.
It's the name of the chief God of the Pantheon of Canaan.
You strike l,
he who has struggled with God.
We'll talk about the way in which the change of name means a change of
character,
change of essence for the patriarch when we return.